[Music]
it's time now for one more thing judge
jeanine
sad news today
we found out today that ivana trump has
passed at the age of 73
she was an olympic skier from
czechoslovakia she was a model
who escaped communism and came to this
country to america to live the american
dream and live the american dream she
did
she modeled here in the united states
and of course in
1977 she married donald trump in new
york city she was a businesswoman she
was a a style icon
she was someone who was the embodiment
of her time in terms of women and what
they could do and the levels to which
they could succeed
i would fly with her many times on
donald trump's jet she was a lovely
woman she was elegant she had style
and she was very gracious she loved her
family and she loved babies i remember
the last shower that i went to
and i think it was for eric's
last daughter she was there and she was
uh so excited the daughter of uh eric
and laura the daughter's name is
carolina and she was like babies babies
we love babies we want babies and we
want more girls and she was so happy and
so full of energy so full of love she
was a family person she loved her
children she's one of the reasons that
those three kids are all superstars
ivanka and don jr and eric they are
great kids because of ivana
unfortunately um her she is survived by
her mom in addition to her children and
many grandchildren
and she will be missed but i i i say it
with a great deal of sadness uh she was
an incredible woman she was an icon
ivana trump and i know geraldo that you
knew her as well she was a lot more
judged than
just a pretty face uh she did blend
elegance and sophistication uh with the
sensitivity and she maintained her
dignity you remember that whole thing
with the best sex i ever had with marla
maples and uh you know it was a tabloid
story of the of the year uh and she
stayed above the fray she was cool she
was the parent to those three children
uh
ivanka especially i think got a lot from
from her mom in terms of combining uh
you know elegance and sophistication and
a head for business uh it's a terrible
loss i don't know that she was ill i had
no idea uh she died in her apartment
here on the upper east side 64th street
uh you know why they say cardiac arrest
but your heart always stops you know so
i don't know what what took her but she
will be missed she was a great lady yes
beautiful tribute thank you guys very
much hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now